oh we're rolling I'm about to tell you
where the real action starts let's talk
let's do it I can't tell you exactly
what you're gonna see because you will
see everything
take one action
[Music]
hello I'm CeCe Stringer and I play
rosemary Hathaway on Vampire Academy and
here we are in beautiful Elite Spain
we're in a Spanish Monastery and we have
this beautiful castle and that serves as
our Academy
all of our sets have been practical and
so as actors we get to just sort of jump
into this and immerse ourselves in the
physicality of it all
we are currently in the monastery but
the set designers came in and built this
maroy dorm hallway to the rich and open
class problems go easy on the starch
I have a feeling that someone's in this
room someone who might like to see me
hey what's up guys
and this is my room I think it's so
colorful to really contrast the the
lifeless barracks yeah that's where I
sleep slumming it with the rest of us
now
tell us about the unicorns Christian has
a lovely line where he says listen you
really are a unicorn so naturally I have
17 unicorns in my bedroom
I don't need a man to save me neither do
I it's Andre here I play Christian
rosera this is my room
there's a bunch of books Christian's a
big reader it's old moroy really is kind
of beautiful
Spain is cool man when we first got here
it was a monastery and some fields and a
Vineyard and now if you check out the
set it's completely transformed yeah
it's just it's incredible it's so
magical we see Mia a lot in Victor's
house that's our family home very bougie
very cool where else do I spend time a
little bit in the guardian training
barracks
[Music]
this is where Sonia spends all of her
time the set at night it's so romantic
all of the candles are lit this is her
place
we are at Alita Castle this is where we
shoot a lot of our Royal Court scenes we
have an obligation to everyone not just
the muroy obviously the costumes are
Super Fly check this thing out the
minute I put this outfit on and started
walking around these locations I knew
exactly who the character was behind me
Saint Vladimir's Academy it's just a
pretty romantic and special environment
mind your tone Victor
Touch where we filmed some really
incredible scenes I'd sooner die than
see her family's bloodline on the throne
perhaps the Saints will grant you your
wish
she's got a very great wardrobe personal
favorite is probably the one I've got
now because this is the First dress that
I wore in the show which was just so
cool
I need a favor can you pass this a note
for me for me no way we're currently in
the courtyard for saint vladimirs but by
far one of my favorite places to be was
the dump here bar the whole thing was
designed for us and it's also where we
keep our memorials for all of the Fallen
dampers which I think it's key in the
show to remember that it is life or
death for these guys you're kind of a
guardian nerd aren't you I'm Kira Moore
I've been Dimitri bellikov I'm about to
tell you where the real action starts
fight them this is some cool lights
and cool fights
I'm impressed who it is I play Mason
Ashford he's um better than Dimitri he
has this undying love for Rose I'm more
comfortable on top don't I know it easy
it's my girl the
SE bites are real there is no special
effects everything you see has been
performed which is a credit to the
amazing stuff team we have here that's
just a little bit of what's going on in
the show
this whole experience is once in a
lifetime we have all fell in love with
these characters yeah we've built a
little family here man we've got a
little family we're gonna use like
nothing